the Terminator has spawned multiple
sequels and prequels both in movie
theaters and on television but as good
as it is it's far from a perfect film to
learn how among other things a perfectly
logical thinking machine acts like a
[ __ ]
keep watching for the dumb things
everyone ignored in the Terminator since
he's governed by ruthlessly calculating
artificial intelligence you might assume
that the Terminator would make purely
logical choices watch the movie though
and one of the first things you'll
notice is that his actions absolutely do
not reflect that for one thing you can't
even decide on how quiet he needs to
keep his time-travel murder mission as
soon as he arrives in the 80s for
example the Terminator makes an
immediate effort to get era-appropriate
clothing that will allow him to blend
into 1984 or at least blend in as much
as an insanely jacked Austrian
bodybuilder can anyway this guy's a
couple cans short of a six-pack you
close give him to me now and yet
throughout the movie he draws plenty of
attention to himself and never seems to
care he steals a pile of guns from a gun
shop and murders the owner with a
shotgun this is the loudest possible way
he could do it which will almost
certainly draw the attention of the
police even in what we see in the movie
up to that point it's obvious that he
could totally kill the owner with his
bare hands flip the closed sign over and
lock the door behind him giving him at
least a few hours before anyone thinks
to call the authorities shortly
afterward he kills the first Sarah
Connor he finds in the phone book he
bothers the knock on the door and asked
her name then smashes the door open and
shoots her six times in a quiet
residential neighborhood as with a gun
shop he could have done it all much more
quietly and if he's not going to be
quiet why bother knocking on the door
and asking her name manners
every now and then you come across a
character in a movie who is so annoying
and stupid that you can't help but
despise them as a viewer while the
comparatively intelligent protagonist
doesn't seem to thoroughly hate them as
much as they should such as the case of
Nancy the waitress who ranks among the
most frustrating characters in the
history of film Sarah Connor is working
at a diner when we meet her and not only
is her section filled with increasingly
irate customers a young boy takes the
opportunity to drop a lump of ice cream
in her apron that's when Nancy comes up
behind her and says that nobody's going
to care in a hundred years which is the
kind of contrived zinger that she would
only say if she knew
she was in a movie where time-traveling
robots exterminated human civilization
in the next century then she just bails
without even bothering to help her
friend and co-worker clean up the mess
and might not seem that bad but don't
worry Nancy goes completely off the
rails a few minutes later after the
Terminator kills another woman named
Sarah Connor and makes the news Nancy
grabs Sarah and pulls her into the break
room to watch the report giving her the
most insane reason ever spoken why would
anyone love hearing about how someone
with their name was violently murdered
what's wrong with you Nancy she's just
lucky she didn't say this stuff to the
super buff T to Sarah Connor who would
have absolutely punched her lights out
for what Kyle Reese says he didn't have
a lot of time to prepare for his trip
into the past after he's arrested Reese
tells the police psychologist that John
Connors forces found a time machine and
a lab complex that captured Reese was
sent to the 20th century and the lab
complex was destroyed even if they were
hustling to get to the past though which
seems like a weird concern when you have
a time machine
shouldn't John Connor have taken a
couple of minutes to remind Reese that
it was probably going to be tough to
protect his mom if she thought he was
completely insane
the first conversation the two
characters have after Ari storms into a
nightclub blasting at a gun-toting
assailant which to put it mildly is a
pretty stressful situation involves
Reese overloading Sarah with a flood of
ridiculously precise information about
the Terminator it's like he's reading
the instruction manual going on about
its microprocessor controlled hyper
alloy combat chassis that's not
information that Sarah would care about
or even understand in the best of times
let alone when it's being shouted at her
by a sweaty man with a shotgun her
initial reaction once Reese pulls into a
parking garage Sarah understandably
tries to escape
biting Reese's hand hard enough to draw
blood can you blame her Reese is from a
bleak apocalyptic future filled with
killer robots so the world of 1984 is
probably as weird to him as he is to
Sarah
but someone definitely should have given
him some tips on how to start up a
conversation with another human being
and even if they didn't Reese is a smart
guy starting off slow and then easing
Sarah Connor into the world of the hyper
alloy combat chassis would seem like a
pretty obvious strategy as you may
already know the Terminator is pretty
difficult to destroy
it doesn't feel pity or remorse or fear
and it absolutely will not stop ever for
the most part the best Kyle Reese can do
is slow the Terminator down but as the
film progresses the cyborg shows more
and more signs of battle damage
eventually he's completely stripped of
all flesh revealing his mechanical
interior the first casualties of the
terminators outward human disguise are
his eyebrows which are burned off in an
explosion after he attacked Sarah and
Reese and a nightclub it makes sense
that he'd lose them too since they
naturally be singed off of that kind of
fire what doesn't make sense is that the
eyebrows are all the Terminator loses in
that fight the same exploding gas tank
that engulfs his entire body and
completely erases his eyebrows is not
absolutely nothing - the hair on his
head nor do his clothes seem at all
damaged by the flames you could maybe
write off the clothes by assuming that
the punk that Terminator stole his
outfit from invested in a fireproof
wardrobe for some unexplained reason but
for the hair there's no excuse even
stranger the scene happens right before
Reese has a conversation with Sarah
where he explicitly tells her that this
model of Terminator has fully organic
skin and hair covering up its metal
skeleton if those eyebrows are going
Arnold's perfect QWOP should be dust -
after showing up in 1984 and eventually
finding a pair of pants Reese tries to
explain the future to Sarah as best he
can he covers the emergence of Skynet
and the resulting nuclear holocaust the
rise of the terminators and their grim
plans for Humanity he explains it all
but the audience is left with a mystery
how does Reese or John Connor or anyone
else in the future even know about
Skynet
or how their world came under the
literal iron fist in the machines
obviously the survivors would know that
the machines were in charge but when you
think about it it isn't quite so obvious
to figure out how the human resistance
ever learned about the creation of
Skynet from what Reese tells us
Skynet decided the fates of the human
race in a millisecond all of that
presumably took place within the a ice
processors with the human race left
scattered and without access to
technology or the power to make that
technology work how could anyone be able
to access the data necessary to
determine how the world went sideways
they don't necessarily need to know in
order to fight back but they certainly
need a way to discover it if they're
going to go back in time and explain it
to Sarah Connor the big twist of the
Terminator is
of course that it's all one big loop
after traveling back in time at the
request of John Connor recent Sara get
it on and in the process they conceived
that same John Connor humanity Savior
who wouldn't exist if it wasn't for the
mission that he ordered Pat's Destiny
baby even if you can get your head
around all the time travel hijinks
though the fact that their brief affair
even happens is just a little weird if
not majorly weird while they're on the
run from The Terminator
Reese ends up confessing to Sara that
her unborn son gave him a picture of her
which he kept and obsessed over for
years he tells her that he fell in love
with her because of that photo without
ever meeting her or talking to her it's
more than just a little creepy Sara is
obviously still reeling from being
hunted by a killer cyborg from the
future
not to mention being on the run from the
authorities and having her roommate
murdered and yet even with all that
learning that this sweaty weirdo became
obsessed with her thanks to a photograph
that she hasn't even taken yet is the
weirdest thing that's happened to her
why doesn't she freaked out even more
or maybe she's into it we're not judging
it just seems like most first dates that
start off with time from the future are
already going to be in enough jeopardy
without adding and I used to just stare
at your picture for hours on end when
he's first being interviewed by the
condescending police psychologist 3 says
that things in the future are actually
starting to look up for the few
remaining humans under the leadership of
John Connor they had won the battle
against Skynet then smashed the machines
Defense Grid sending the Terminator back
in time was a last ditch effort on the
machines parts made out of desperation
by this elaborate scheme with the
Terminator it had no choice their
Defense Grid was smashed we'd won that's
good news for Humanity but from what
little we see of the future it's kind of
hard to believe in both scenes we see of
the future first with Reese and his
fellow soldiers being defeated by a
flying machine and then with a
terminator infiltrating an underground
bunker and killing almost everyone in
sight the humans seem absolutely
hopeless maybe that's just how things
are on the fronts but all of those piles
of skulls aren't exactly cheery
especially since recess to throw
everything he can at the Terminator to
barely slow it down
and eventually dies in the process so
how exactly does John Connor manage to
defeat this unstoppable self-replicating
enemy the humans have barely any
resources and we see
hunt rats for food the fact that they
have any weapon tree at all seems like
at least a minor miracle it's hard to
understand how they could possibly win
no matter how good John is it looking
through binoculars the Terminator ends
with Sarah Connor and Mexico on her way
to becoming the hardened badass we find
in 1991's Terminator 2 Judgment Day
she's got a new dog with her presumably
to detect any other terminators who
might travel through time and she's
recording the sort of journal on tape as
she travels musing on the question of
whether or not she will tell her unborn
son that Kyle Reese was his father of
all the things she could be telling
someone anyone about the future is the
identity of John's father really her
biggest concern a time-travelling
paternity test might make a great
episode for Maury Povich once his show
starts up in 1991 come on Sarah let's
get our priorities straight here of
course that's not to suggest Sarah
should be yelling from the highest
mountain that everyone's going to die
soon thanks to killer robots as we see
in Terminator 2 that's exactly the sort
of thing that lands her in a mental
institution
it's just that in terms of what she
should reveal about the future she's
rating do I tell my son about his dad
over do I tell people they should start
building robot proof shelters check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]